here as you know there are two process
parallel process one is the works of the
joint commission the working groups that
involves all participant states into the
gcpa at the same time we have
the american delegation we have
proximity tax between the iranian and
the american delegation they don't meet
directly as you know but
there are facilitations for this for
this conversation so what has been the
norm over the last over the first six
rounds will be again
the practice in this seventh round
nothing nothing new on working
methods in your own mind
there is a sense of urgency but there is
no fixed timeline on my mind because
there are still difficult issues i have
first
issues politically to be decided and
second we have rather technical complex
technical issues when we will get to the
implementation of the of the different
agreements on sanctions lifting and
nuclear commitment so i wouldn't venture
a date for that but at the same time
it's obvious
that we need to work and to go ahead
okay thank you
thank you